let's get it in today [ __ ] we
gonna do this y'all ready I'm Oh what's
going on YouTube oh we bout to get into
it today we don't talk about topic
that's been on my mind
can I ask y'all something this is a very
very serious question what the [ __ ] is
everything nowadays have to be so
politically correct
you know what politically correct is
it's just another word used today so
everybody in this world can be happy
because they don't want to be offended
by anybody's words and that's [ __ ]
stupid
now I'm not going as far to say as words
can't hurt people because words are very
strong as much as they can be positive
they can be that destructive as well so
yes you have to use your common sense
when it comes to saying certain things
but I feel like in today's society you
just can't say [ __ ] well guess what
that's why you have Davis no comedy
channel you know why because I must say
all your [ __ ] for you political
correctness [ __ ] you people don't even
really know what it is to really be
politically correct anymore they just go
as far as to say you just don't want to
offend anybody say everything's super
nice and let the world be flower but do
you know why this new generation of
being politically correct is so stupid
it be young people using it in the wrong
way because that's not life I think a
lot of us today are [ __ ] spoiled
meaning that any type of negativity that
comes at you you feel like it shouldn't
happen that's not life in life things
are supposed to happen
not every way that you wanted [ __ ] is
going to happen that's the type of [ __ ]
that I grew up which is why for me in my
personal opinion I have a stronger
talent but something comes my way it
tries to break me down I tell them to
shut the [ __ ] up and I deal with that
[ __ ] though one of this has to do with
being politically correct everybody
wants everything to be PC because they
don't want to deal with problems they
don't want to deal with negativity well
guess what [ __ ] happens
you can't use the word [ __ ] anymore
because it's a word that's described for
women and you're saying the only women
are [ __ ] no when I use the word [ __ ]
I use it for males and females you's a
[ __ ] you's a [ __ ] you I can't say
anything I can't joke about anything
because it's going to [ __ ] offend you
get over it [ __ ] like I said
there are certain things that
should be complained about there are
certain things that do need to change
but not everything there's always a
counter for something that you're saying
today that has something to do with you
being a [ __ ] up person in society
nobody is a hoe
nobody is fat nobody is stupid
that's not real there are always people
in this world there are stupid people in
this world there are fat people in this
world I happen to be one of those stupid
people I happen to be what those fat
people but I know how people just don't
want to be labeled things that they
actually are and the reason why you hate
those things because you hate it about
yourself even on this PC sense we can't
even say somebody's overweight so let's
go back on that fat shaming topic right
it's something that I [ __ ] hate
because I'm somebody who's trying to
lose weight now I'm not trying to lose
weight because I don't love myself it's
because I know I'm fat meaning that
maybe that means I am unhealthy nobody
is telling you that you are less of a
human being because you are fat if
anything you are more mature with me
those type of issues are internal stuff
that you have to deal with yourself
once again fat shaming people is telling
somebody because they are fat they are
less of a person that's fat shaming
saying that somebody is overweight and
out of shape and they need to change
that in order to get their health better
it's not that shaming that is positive
reinforcement PC police suck on my
[ __ ] nuts you can't even tell
somebody who is sitting at home not
doing [ __ ] with no aspirations not even
looking to find a career that they are a
lazy [ __ ] because now you are somebody
who doesn't understand their story your
story is that you are a waste of space
and when Jesus D's occur you were born
another big reason why being too
politically correct nowadays is stupid
is because it's unrealistic anybody you
like that thinks that life is always
supposed to go their way is setting
themselves up for [ __ ] failure do you
think the clouds before it rains is
thinking to the people down there well I
don't want to cause no traffic Diane no
the clouds don't give a [ __ ] about you
and sometimes a life don't give a [ __ ]
about you and by the way when you ask a
community to always be politically
correct guess what it's not going to
[ __ ] happen
our job is to make fun of [ __ ] like that
we're supposed to make fun of the norm
and find humor and [ __ ] that normally
isn't funny
that's our job we are comedians [ __ ] you
any idea how sorry would be for
comedians to only talk about stuff
that's supposed to be talked about hey
you guys ever wake up in the morning and
ahahahahaha on at the end of the day
what I am saying is don't be a [ __ ]
learn to toughen up a little bit and
speak up about things that are extremely
important because normally the people
who are so PC are a lot about the
insignificant things but the things that
are huge and important you guys are
[ __ ] silent you know why cuz you're a
[ __ ] you don't like competition and
when it really counts you're not there
PC police suck my [ __ ] balls hey what
is going on guys I hope you guys like
that video but before you guys leave I
got some dope [ __ ] for y'all now you
guys know I have been a major supporter
of slugs books you guys have seen it on
my channel a couple of times well I'm
back with slug books again now for those
of you in college you guys already know
textbooks are [ __ ] expensive and
that's where slug books comes in to save
you some gwap some cash some scrilla
some plug book compares all the prices
of the cheapest sights online so you can
save money let's go ahead and break it
down how you're gonna do this find the
ISBN number of the books or book you
need in college you can go in and check
that out by your professor or your
bookstores website before you even start
the class and find the cheapest book
that's it now if you go to the slug book
now if you go to the slug books calm
link in the description below you'll go
ahead and see the website there with a
cute little cartoon version of me and go
ahead and start saving that money now
for those of you out there to have you
slug books you guys already know how
useful this [ __ ] website is so go
ahead and check that out let me know how
much money you save and then buy me
dinner [ __ ] cuz I'm hungry let's
urgency sometimes books are like 200 and
300 dollars online and I'll slug but you
could probably find it for about 10 to
15 or 20 bucks you never know but I will
see y'all next time let me know what you
think about that website and uh
I'm just [ __ ] laughing Kenobi